Mama stare violin, just hang on. He's coming.
How many genre movies can you think of with LGBT characters playing the heroes
in the 1990s, Solano Chesky asked herself that exact question.
My brain, one.
Of had this revelation after watching the silence of the lambs in theaters,
which despite being an artistic triumph follows a long line of films like psycho
dressed to kill and sleepaway camp where trans or gender fluid characters are
not only the villains, but actually deranged psycho killers.
There have been sympathetic, characters, especially in more recent films,
but the films almost always fit into one of two categories,
either they're lighthearted comedies or they're total downers,
but they're which house keys wanted to do something different.
They wanted to make a movie with sympathetic characters. That was a genre movie.
First,
it would start a lesbian couple while still delivering the suspense and action
of a classic new Warfield in the 1990s that had never been done before in a
mainstream film.
But a lot of which house key enter sister Lily did exactly that when they wrote
in directed bound, the greatest lesbian gangster heist movie ever made.
[Inaudible].
In 1994, the which house key sold two of their scripts to Warner brothers.
The first was bound and the second was another film.
They also wanted to direct the studio.
Didn't trust them to direct the second film because it was much more expensive.
So they made bound first,
which gave the studio the confidence to let them direct their second film,
a big budget Saifai with lots of fight scenes and special effects.
You may have heard of it. Do you know what I'm talking about?
The matrix, the matrix contains many now iconic techniques,
but bounce did a lot of them first, just on a smaller scale. In fact,
bounce has an early version of the now famous three 60 shot,
and it has bullets in slow motion.
There's a terrific shot of the bullet flying through the air.
If you look at it carefully,
you can actually see the piece of led in a kind of very simple and formative
way. That's the origins of bullet time.
All the major crew for the matrix first collaborated together on bound,
including the editor, cinematographer, composer, and sound designer.
And once you explore bounds, incredible understanding of the genre,
filmmaking techniques and character development.
It's no surprise that this creative team would go on to make a film as
influential as the matrix bounce stars. Two women Corky,
a Butch lesbian who just got out of prison and file it a more feminine woman.
Who's dating Caesar, a money launderer for the mob.
The story revolves around the two women becoming lovers and hatching,
a plan to steal $2 million from Caesar and the mafia there.
Heist starts off as planned quirky,
steals the money and hides it in the apartment. Next door.
Once Caesar finds out the money is stolen and they expect him to run away,
but he instead stays,
put and tries to convince the mafia that he didn't take the money from here.
The plan spirals out of control in an homage to classic black and white noir
films. Many of the shots in the film look almost completely black and white and
cinematographer, bill Pope employed, film techniques popular in the 1950s,
such as high contrast in unbalanced composition to create a sense of unease.
As Caesar tries to find the stolen money,
his lighting gets more and more extreme showing his gradual descent into
madness, such extreme lighting techniques were common in old Nawar movies,
like double indemnity and the Maltese Falcon, along with the Nawar visuals.
The story also has noir elements, including an intricate plot,
a looming sense of doom and deceptive, morally ambiguous characters.
Violet embodies the femme fatale,
a noir character who uses her beauty to seduce and manipulate unsuspecting men.
When talking to men,
violet raises the pitch of her voice to appear more delicate and helpless,
and even quirky is initially suspicious of her flirtation.
All these tropes in bounds show that what Chelsea's understanding of genre,
but where the film truly shines. It's not an Sri creation of past genres,
but in how it builds on top of them and create something completely new.
The film does use monochromatic lighting like old black and white films,
but it's one, it breaks that rule that the film gets created.
Oh my God, don't worry. They mine.
With such a de-saturated film.
The which house keys used color to make things stand out color.
Most often emphasizes the bloody violence,
but it also makes Johnny's cartoonish suit stand out,
showing his immaturity in the scene where violet seduces Corky her purple
lipstick is often the only color in the shot,
which draws attention to her sexuality in the same way that color challenges,
the visual design of Nawara Violet's character plays with the expectations of
the Fenty towel defense.
The towel typically turns on the main character while quirky and violet plan the
heist. We still don't know for sure if we can trust violet.
She me.
The which house keys use the expected betrayal of the femme fatale to raise the
tension. But in the end, violet, doesn't do what we expected. Instead,
we get to see in a war film where we actually root for the femme fatale rather
than fear her. It totally flips the genre on its head.
This time the male gangster is the antagonist and the femme fatale is the
protagonist in previous Wars. The femme fatale tricks,
the main character as well as the audience, but inbound,
the audience is in on the deception since we know violet and Corky's plan from
the beginning.
This shift in perspective creates a film full of dramatic irony intention
because we know everything about the heist.
Even if all the male characters don't have a clue from the beginning,
the women are in control of both the frame and the story when Corky and violet
first meet in the elevator, they clearly check each other out,
but all that flirting literally happens behind Caesar's back.
Unlike in most Chaunra films, the witch house keys wanted to make violet a calm,
calculated heroine.
They even had to reshoot an entire scene to make sure they didn't portray her as
stereotypically frantic or over the top.
I thought this would be a really good place for violet to reveal all the anger
that she had percolating below the surface, but I was wrong.
It would have been great if it was a Scorsese picture,
but this is not a Scorsese picture. So I.
Understand why they want three.
Violence. Predicament.
Inbound actually has a lot in common with the particulate of Karen and Martin
Scorsese, film Goodfellas,
both characters are trapped in a relationship with a guy who works for the
mafia.
Both films have a similar scene where the woman has the opportunity to shoot her
man, but they turn out quite differently.
The Goodfellas scene follows the tradition of many Nawar films,
like the Maltese, Falcon, the killers, and double indemnity,
where the women act frantic and unheroic,
and their fight against men feels desperate.
Now I won't spoil exactly how this scene in bound ends,
but let's just say that violet doesn't have that problem.
Caesar. You don't know.
I love this line because it almost feels like violet is addressing the audience
like Caesar. We had expectations for how this film would play out.
We expected violet would portray quirky.
We expected Caesar would keep his cool and we expected the women to be the
victims, but like Caesar, we got tricked bounds,
toying with genre and refreshing ways is enough to make it a classic.
But another element of the film elevates it to the greatest lesbian gangster
heist movie ever made.
I don't think so.
Is one of the first, if not the first mainstream genre movies,
starring a sympathetic lesbian couple and the witch house keys hired lesbian
author and critic,
Susie bright to help them execute this concept in an authentic way together.
They changed how movies portray sex,
both literally and symbolically by focusing on the feminine aspects of sex.
This movie is so wet. This kind of style, you know, gangster movies.
Everything's about a hard-on everything's about being hard.
And this movie was just wet, dripping wet all the time.
Inbound the hand represents sex.
A concept that according to bright resonated with the lesbian community, right?
Hands are the sex organs in this.
And every lesbian understood that who saw the movie.
So for the first time in an awar flick the witch house keys have a brand new
symbol at their disposal. The hand becomes a sex object. Pants unite,
the two characters and symbolize Corky and Violet's connection.
When Cesar threatens to cut off Violet's fingers, it's a form of castration.
The films shows sexuality in a distinctly lesbian way,
especially in how Corky and violet present themselves quirky is the masculine
Butch lesbian and violet is the girly fan playing into those stereotypes,
leads to some of the humor in the film like when violet correctly,
guesses that Corky is good with her hands.
I'll bet. Your car is 20 years old,
truck truck course,
63 Chevy. I knew it.
Still never reduces the two lesbians to caricature. In fact,
the two frequently break their stereotypes. When violet is alone with Corky,
she downplays her fem side,
lowering her pitch and wearing jeans instead of a dress and violet isn't the
innocent curious woman seduced by the more confident lesbian it's the exact
opposite.
Yes.
Cesar breaks from the expectations of atypical gangster.
He's actually one of the more feminine characters in the film instead of the
woman getting jealous like in Goodfellas Caesar is the one who hates the Gianni
flirts with violent of all the characters. He's the most hysterical.
And he even looks like a housewife when he puts on a smock and irons,
all of the money by playing with the expected roles of violet Corky and Caesar,
the which house keys create a brand new story while still delivering the thrills
of a conventional a war. The film received praise,
not just for its brand new plot, but also for its brand new portrayal of.
I'm just here to get laid.
At the time that which house keys made bound to films about gay characters,
almost always showed them either ashamed or uncertain of their sexuality.
And that's a trend that continues to this day,
but violet and Corky break that trend by not regretting their sex at all. So.
I don't think I can stand as women are apologize for lining.
Sex,
the films unabashedly gay story combined with its clear understanding of lesbian
culture led to many in the community, embracing the film.
It was shown in the Castro theater, and it was filled with lesbians.
When the movie was over,
the entire theater was pounding on the floor with her feet.
The theater was literally literally rocking. I mean, it was moving.
I've seen the power of this film firsthand.
I recommended it to a friend who ended up loving it so much.
She got a tattoo of violet on her arm. She even included a labyrinth.
The same object Corky has tattooed on her arm, which symbolizes the matriarchy.
The symbol suits this film quite well because Corky and violet both overcome the
usual boundaries set on women in the war and gangster films.
Corky crosses that boundary by playing a role typically given to a man and
violet crosses that boundary by defying the expectations of the femme fatale.
It's got stacks of letters from fans all over the country saying it is so great
to see a woman who they think she's going to be the photographer and they think
she's going to be Trey and let go.
And she ends up being so competent and so real and so reliable.
You never get to see a reliable fam in this kind of movie. So it was just,
it was a great day for womankind.
Found,
just goes to show that you don't need to sacrifice the thrills of a genre film
to include women and LGBT people in your story. On the contrary,
those identities can make your film more interesting because they give the
filmmaker an opportunity to push the boundaries of what could happen in a Nawara
gangster or heist film, who bound challenges,
the established rules of genre films.
So it's no surprise that the film itself is about breaking rules and crossing
boundaries.
In the film Caesar tries to create boundaries by preventing things from entering
and exiting his apartment.
He doesn't let violet leave while they torture Shelly.
And he tries to keep Johnny quiet, to prevent sound from escaping,
making too much noise. He even attempts to control Corky early on.
He forces her to accept some money so he can keep her under his thumb.
But despite all his best efforts, the boundaries of his apartment are fluid.
Corky can hear through the walls.
And violet allows her to enter and exit freely.
One of the coolest examples of fluid boundaries is when violin and Corky make
their to steal the mafia's money. And instead of cutting between two locations,
Corky appears like an apparition in Violet's apartment to talk through the plan,
come to a place in the morning.
So it's only appropriate that Caesar realizes something is up by hearing a phone
ring through his walls.
He gets a literal wake-up call that the boundaries of his apartment aren't as
secure as he thought,
but the boundaries don't stop violent and Corky even with a wall,
separating them. They still connect
In the end, the use of genre, the characters and the story all cross boundaries.
So if you're wondering why the film is called bound,
that's why the title of the film does a great job of showing the multiple ideas
expressed in the film.
The most obvious meaning of bound is to be restricted like when Corky is bound
by rope in the opening of the film,
but the promotional art for the film clearly shows that being bound with rope
also has sexual connotations echoing the non-traditional lesbian relationship at
the center of the story.
But if you want to go even deeper bounds also means certain to do something
quirky and violet are bound to escape their predicaments and follow their
destiny. And this is a story,
not bound to genre rules,
and also not bound to conventional sexual and gender identities.
And even though a child skis themselves have crossed boundaries,
years after bound came out, both which housekeepers came out as trans women,
which adds another layer of meaning to their early work with their coming out as
trans bounces,
positive representation of the LGBT community feels that much more personal.
And like the matrix, both films deserve close readings with a transgender lens.
For example,
both films have a moment where one person thinks another character is a man,
but that character is actually a woman in the matrix. Neo assumes.
Trinity will be a man.
I just thought you were a guy.
And inbound Caesar assumes violet is hooking up with a guy,
but it turns out she's with a woman.
Dark.
In so many ways the which house keys,
Susie bright and the rest of the production team made a film that escaped the
bounds of what a genre movie can be. So if you haven't watched this film,
all I ask is that you give it a shot because I have a feeling you'll enjoy
watching the greatest lesbian gangster heist movie.
[Inaudible].
The which house keys.
First director of photography for bound actually dropped out because he didn't
think he could make their film with their budget in the end,
bill Pope signed on and helped them execute their vision on a shoestring budget.
Great movie made for nothing. That to me is a perfect little gym.
These days,
you don't need an agent or production company to learn how to shoot video on a
lower budget to do that.
You can watch Christopher road's class on that exact topic,
where he goes in depth on how to maximize your budget for a video project.
You can watch that class and thousands more by getting a free trial of the
Skillshare premium membership.
Skillshare is an online learning community with thousands of inspiring classes
for creative and curious people, including classes on photography,
content creation, and video editing, explore new skills,
deepen existing passions, and get lost in creativity with Skillshare,
you can be like the witch house keys and make your creative vision a reality
click on the link in the description to explore your creativity.
And the first 1000 people to use our link will get a free trial of Skillshare
premium membership.
Thanks to Skillshare for sponsoring this video and a big thanks to my Patrion
supporters who make this channel possible.
There's a new podcast episode ready for all the $5 patrons. Thanks for watching.